well there's been another mass shooting
this one at a school this one the
deadliest school shooting since sandy
hook elementary school shooting in 2012.
and um
guys this is this is not normal uh
yesterday i did a story about how we've
had 210 mass shootings so far in 2022
and while i was doing that segment i
noticed that a 211th shooting had been
added from monday so yesterday tuesday
morning i recorded that segment and in
the time from when i gathered the data
to when i recorded the segment
a monday shooting had been added to the
list so while i was talking we went from
210 to 211 mass shootings
before that segment published yesterday
a 212th mass shooting this year took
place
another teen gunman at an elementary
school in uvalde texas
killed his grandmother before going to
school
as of right now 19 dead the shooter also
dead the shooter bought the guns legally
when he turned 18. in other words the
law worked to the extent that this was
someone that
got the guns legally and then
we had this shooting
now of course
it's hard to know all the details so
soon after the event the details so far
are horrifying for example one new
detail is all of the deaths happened in
one classroom in the school
imagine the carnage that we're talking
about here even for the kids that
survived
unspeakable
as always
mental illness is being brought up by
the right as the sole factor and cause
here and it's like a broken record but
as i've said before
the mental illness element is not an
either or after the buffalo shooting and
now as well we're hearing the right that
doesn't want to talk about guns and
availability of guns talk only about
mental illness
it's not an either or
often there's a mental illness component
and if that's what we believe we should
make mental health treatment
more accessible more affordable easier
to get
just about every republican is against
that they will say when we try to expand
access to all health care including
mental health coverage these republicans
who say the mass shootings which are an
epidemic are merely a mental illness
problem they say no weak but what you
want to do is a government takeover of
health care what you want to do is
socialism so the first thing is if they
really
want to deal with this as a mental
health issue why do they vote against
every opportunity to expand access and
reduce cost to mental health care number
two we have to say
most mentally ill people are not violent
and never commit any violent acts or
crimes so sometimes there's the reaction
from some in my audience to say even
mentioning mental illness is an insult
to the mentally ill
well it's not about being an insult it's
just that
almost never do mentally ill people
commit crimes or become violent now
for the small percentage that does
if there are fewer guns around if it's
more difficult to get guns in general
whatever violence mentally ill people
try to commit will be less lethal
if
the mentally ill people who would kill
20 with assault rifles can only get a
handgun maybe they only kill five if
they can't even get the handgun
maybe they can only kill one with a
knife or you get the point okay so even
if we concede there's a mental illness
component well we should fund dealing
with it and it would still be better if
those few mentally ill people who want
to commit violence have a harder time
getting guns
at the end of the day this is an issue
of more than one thing number one
too much and too easy access to guns
that's one piece
number two we have a cultural problem in
the united states in the united states
i don't want to say it's necessarily
celebrated although in some places it is
it's
looked at as plausibly okay by too many
people in the united states
that it's okay to use firearms to solve
interpersonal or societal problems
can't find a girl
well maybe use a gun to go and do
something
disaffected by society having a conflict
that work the disgruntled employee
shootings like we saw on public transit
in california what was it a year ago six
months ago 18 months ago i don't even
remember so that is another component
there's a there's a real cultural issue
in the united states and number three
there is the element of untreated and
undiagnosed mental illness as a result
of the disastrous health care system
that republicans refuse to fix
the same people who are saying the only
problem is mental health are the ones
who consistently vote not to expand
access to mental health treatment
there's mental health issues everywhere
it's important to know in the united
states there's way more guns and way
more easy access to guns and that's a
unique issue in the united states we
also have issues with access and costs
when it comes to mental health treatment
so there's there's violent video games
everywhere
there's mental health issues everywhere
so when a republican or anybody else
says this is just about mental illness
ask what legislation they supported to
fund mental health treatment to make it
affordable to make it accessible
one other thing on this
you also have to understand
the absurdity of republican arguments
about how limiting access to guns would
achieve nothing for years republicans
have been saying
if you explain to kids
how to have safe sex and you give them
access to condoms and birth control
pills
they're going to have more sex
and they won't take the birth control
pills correctly or whatever and and it's
going to be more unwanted pregnancy if
you if you do that you're going to get
more unwanted pregnancy
they've said for years if you have these
harm reduction safe drug use sites
it's going to encourage more drug use
and it's going to lead to more overdose
but then they want to say more access to
guns has no impact on gun violence that
doesn't really make any sense but
meanwhile they say if you ban abortion
you'll end abortion well if that's true
why wouldn't limiting access to guns at
least to reduce mass shootings oh no no
no that's different nothing will work to
stop this
say people in the only country where
this regularly happens well that doesn't
make sense we've really tried nothing
but we're out of ideas the only thing we
have is arming teachers which we're
going to get to in a moment
aren't we at the point where it's worth
trying some gun safety regulations along
with other things just to see if it's
work do what many other countries have
done with great success
and see if it works here i mean parents
had to provide
dna samples because their kids bodies
were mutilated beyond recognition to try
to figure out who are these dead kids we
can't even talk about gun safety
regulations and now they're they're back
on the arm teachers train which i want
to talk about next